[Music]
and number 8 choice is actually a tie
which I know a lot of you are saying hey
that's cheating but fuck it's my list
I'll do whatever the hell I want it's my
favorite duo in the whole wide world
Myles and Jack from sideways I think I
actually would like these two
individually they both have very
different adventures and very different
personalities and very different goals
but putting them together they offset
each other and complement each other so
well
that it's pretty difficult not to enjoy
them hate them feel sorry for them
wanna smack them but in other ways
actually respect them all at the same
time Myles is taking Jack on a tour of
wine country as his best man gift but
Jax wears a different vow
he's gonna get miles late as he's just
been too damn depressed ever since his
divorce they come across two women which
they both have the hots for and really
like their personalities and decide
these are the perfect additions to their
trip well okay now both of them Jack is
the only one that sees the opportunity
but he's very good at convincing Myles
that there is something great to be had
here both of them get more than they
bargained for both good and bad Jack
decides he may actually like his
girlfriend played by Sandra Oh more than
his actual fiancee and Myles he's a
romantic relationship looming as well
but his two insecure and constantly
strikes out both of them can be
considered incredibly despicable for
this Jack for being such an idiot and
not taking responsibility for his
decisions and Myles for being so
insecure and not actually telling the
truth as well as not taking the chances
that he should so you might be thinking
hey these sound like two assholes well
in many respects they kind of are but in
other respects the reason they make such
a good duo is because they really do
come together to complete something
likable Myles would never open up if
Jack wasn't there to push him and Jack
will keep making dumb decision after
dumb decision if Myles wasn't there to
talk some sense into him so they keep
continuing to try to keep the other in
balance I think I like these two as a
duo because it actually does show the
importance of human interaction yeah I
know that sounds kind of obvious but as
much as we like to say oh I like this
character as an individual or this
character as an individual here's the
team that really do need each other
their constant conversations and
bickering really do balance each other
out
sometimes one needs a push sometimes
needs to be pulled back sometimes one
needs to get the other out of trouble
sometimes one needs to get the other
into trouble it's a perfect example of
taking risks but also playing it safe
and when you need both to actually make
something positive when you get down to
the story of sideways it's not
especially interesting which is to say I
didn't exactly know where it was going
to go but that's not what held my
interest in the movie what helped my
interest was these two characters I was
so fascinated how I could both admire
them and despise them both at the same
time and for entirely different reasons
than the other everything I hated about
Jack I admire about Myles and everything
I hated about Myles I admire about Jack
which is why you can see it's so hard to
separate these two they just both meld
together so perfectly
perhaps if you combine these two
together and took the best traits out of
both of them and remove the worst traits
from both of them you could have a very
successful awesome person but that's no
fun we want a little bit more reality we
want a little bit more meat to it we
want to see why it's good to disagree
with others and to take chances and to
play it safe and the benefits of all the
opportunities out there that's why I put
these two both in the number eight spot
they can be funny serious admirably
pathetic charming awkward but always
entertaining they're one of my favorite
duo's from one of my favorite movies
[Music]
you